so first off it's about 300,000 miles
and I was actually talking to Emily
Robinson a couple days ago because I was
having a panic attack about what's a
good fact about me and I told her that
fact it's like oh I think was gonna use
this and she's like Oh ever you like
done an analysis on that data and are
and I'm like that's a good idea
so anyway hi I'm Jacqueline Dulles and
look the last talk of the day I'm the
one thing standing between you and
alcohol like I get it but um and and
worse you know we're talking about deep
learning and deep learning is hard but
deep learning isn't hard I promise
so we're gonna start with a linear
regression linear regression that's not
hard right we know what a linear
regression is a linear regression is you
take some X's you multiply them each by
a coefficient and you get a Y and you
fit those coefficients you get like a
line thing we've seen these charts
before hopefully so that's the linear
regression we got that but what's deep
learning and oh and by the way this
presentation is gonna be filled with
some pets to just keep it nice keep it
comfortable last talk of the day cute
pets so what's deep learning deep
learning it starts with these weird
network charts you see all the time
right you see these charts they look
complicated you think you can't do that
they're not linear regressions they're
weird dots and lines but there's a trick
they're actually just linear regressions
so deep learning deep learning is
powerful because really what you're
doing is you're just taking a bunch of
linear regressions and stringing them
together so each one of those top nodes
is those same X as you are using in a
linear regression each one the middle
nodes is a linear regression that each
line says feed those X's in and so you
have a row of linear regression so you
got three written linear regressions and
the output of those gets fed into two
more linear regressions which gets fed
into one more linear regression which
that output is y and so it's still a
bunch of linear regression so you can
think about deep learning in many ways
in the exact same way you would think
about linear regressions now in a linear
regression you do some stuff to fit that
line and in deep learning you do a lot
more to fit that line but as someone
who's using deep learning you really
don't have to think too much about that
so what
worry about that and importantly deep
learning is funny so here's some
Internet examples someone used deep
learning to generate new D&D spells by
feeding at old D&D spells someone made
new Pokemon by feeding it the names of
old existing Pokemon and someone took
did a Freedom of Information Act on the
state of Arizona to get all of the
banned license plates that were too
offensive and generated new offensive
license plates on them that person was
me and so we learned earlier today I
keep leaning into this mic but the mics
here I don't know why I'm doing that we
learned earlier today that deep learning
can be used to like solve to find cures
to diseases but it can also be used if
you desperately crave attention on the
Internet so what are we gonna do we're
gonna do deep learning in our and
there's one package that really helps us
do it it's called Karis it's by art
studio it's great it's it's really
modern it uses the tidy syntax that
we're used to if you use the tidy verse
and actually secretly in the background
it's running Python but you don't have
to worry about that just don't like
really feel like the beginner and
intermediate product that you don't have
to think about that at all and
importantly it doesn't require expensive
computer so when you hear people
bragging about how many GPUs and
millions of rows they have to do to get
to deep learning to work know that you
can do it on your five-year-old computer
so our project is let's make some pet
names and we're gonna do it using data
from the city of Seattle
oh and by the way these pet pictures are
all from people in the our community who
generously donated them and we're gonna
take those names and get rid of them and
put in some new funny names that deep
Learning Network generated and there's
gonna be some code that's discussed here
but all that code will be available is
available online and you can see it
there's gonna be like again at the end
of the talk so don't worry too much if
you don't get it right now so what's the
data the data is years of pet flight
since records from the City of Seattle
we only care about the name in this case
you could use the other sets of stuff
but we really care about the name and we
really want to learn the rules right so
like M R is probably mister so you
follow it by a space like the top named
mr. Darcy there's lots of these rules
that are hidden inside the names that we
want the neural network to learn and use
to generate new names so the first step
was we need to format the data and just
like a linear regression needs a matrix
of X data and an output of Y data our
neural network is going to need that too
and what we want to do is we want to
predict for each like part of the way
through a name we want to predict what
the next letter is so what we have to do
is take all of the names that are in the
database right now and decompose them
into sets of each predicted next letter
and so you can see here if we have the
name spot that we can actually create
five data points for we can try and
predict what the starting letter is
which is the top row to predict if you
have five blanks predict s and then if
you have four blanks and S predict P s
and P predict o and so on and so forth
and then at the end point you try and
say SP ot spot will then predict the
name is over and so this will be the
training data that we're going to use on
our neural network and nothing to create
you have to create that data set but
nothing of that has to do with deep
learning at all that's just doing some
data manipulation that you may have to
do in other projects as well so then we
have to convert the letters to numbers
so just like a linear regression deep
learning can't reason in letters you
have to feed it in a set of numbers so
we're gonna do two things what we're
gonna do a lot of things but two things
first we're gonna start by creating a
dictionary so we're gonna say a is 1 B
is 2 just like you're encoding a message
to send to some friend when you're in
high school to keep the teachers not
noticing well you you you code the
letters as numbers and then we're gonna
do one hot encoding so we're gonna say
for each number because we don't want
like a to be close to B to be close to C
if you want each one of these things to
be independent we're gonna replace each
number with a sequence of zeros and ones
with a zeros with one one that's going
to represent the number so three would
be zero zero one zero zero and they'd be
like 25 zeros and this is the same thing
you would do in other places like if
you're doing a linear regression on
categorical data you do the same thing
we're gonna do that with our letters to
turn them into a set of binary set of
data and so if we do those steps
together like blank blank Espio becomes
a sequence of numbers which then becomes
a sequence of sequences of zeros and
ones and so the ends up meaning the
input is a 3-dimensional binary matrix
and the size of the number of training
rows by the maximum length of our name
by the number of characters in our
dictionary ie 26 or like 27 if you
include a space
and the target why's the two-dimensional
matrix because we have the number of
training rows and the number of possible
characters the next character could be
okay so we formatted that data and now
it's time to make the neural network but
how are we gonna design that Network and
I apologize I know they said no
questions during the talks and that's a
question so I'm sorry so we're gonna
steal yeah
and so and in particular what we're
gonna do is we're gonna take someone
else's design for a neural network who's
already solved that problem because we
don't have to worry about that step
because it's hard let's let someone else
do that work before we get there let's
talk about what the different types of
layers are so here are four different
types of layers that will show up in a
neural could show up in a neural network
and will show up in our neural network
spoiler alert so first off is the dense
layer so this is the layer that we saw
at the beginning of the talk and it just
says that take everything you have in
the previous layer take all the outputs
and feed each one as an input into the
next layer so everything gets everything
the LS TM layer this layer is really
useful for when you're dealing with
sequences of data and the point of this
is to actually care about the order that
the data showing up in so where's the
dense kind of feeds everything to
everything in a way that you know
doesn't really doesn't really care about
the order what the Alice TM does it says
take the first input train some stuff on
it then pass that to the second then
take the second input train some stuff
on it along with the input the output of
the previous thing and then take the
third input trains itself on it along
with the output of the second thing and
you keep doing this and this is really
helpful because if you imagine that
something like a name has sequenced you
know sequential information in it like
the order of the letters really matters
and so this allows you to consider how
the order of the letters will propagate
through and we have the option with the
LS TM layer to either take each take all
of the output from all of those bottom
nodes or only to care about the last one
the drop out the third the third type of
layer this is to deal with the fact that
neural networks can over fit so if you
imagine if we have all these linear
regressions linear regressions upon
linear regressions we're gonna get a lot
of parameters and if we're not careful
especially if you don't have that much
data we're gonna way over fit to our
training stuff
stuff that's a technical cool and so
what a dropout layer does is it will
remove some of the edges in there and it
will remove some of the data just to
kind of force the network to avoid being
overfitting to the training and then
lastly the activation layer this layer
will apply a function across the values
so you can imagine you may want to say
ensure that all of the outputs add up to
one or all the outputs have at least or
at least value of zero you can apply
functions with an activation layer to do
that so though there's no tools were
going to use when we create our network
so here's here's our network so it's
gonna it's a very few talk when I saw
the picture the dog I thought it was a
stuffed animal at first cuz the ears but
it's not so our network it's gonna start
with our input data so in this case the
inputs data is going to be whatever the
previous letters were in the name and
then we're gonna add an OS TM to try and
figure out what are the sequential
patterns in that name like what can we
cook what can we get from the sequences
of the letters and then we're gonna say
take all of the outputs from all the AHS
TMS and let's get into an LS TM again
because we want to just see if there's
like more patterns more nuances can we
build upon each other now you can
imagine for more complex data we could
have like four or seven LS Sam layers
and when people talk about deep learning
what they really mean is a neural
network where you have enough layers
that it's super complicated so I don't
think this hits that yet but I don't
know so then to drop out layer that's
there to again to avoid overfitting
because especially with this this data
set it's big but it's not so big that
the neural network doesn't have a risk
of overfitting and so then we add a
dense layer and the dense layer here is
really important and it's really
important because what we want to do is
we want to predict for each possible
letter what the probability is that that
letter will be chosen next so if you
imagine there are like let's say twenty
seven layers letters all the letters of
the alphabet and a space they're
actually all there's at the alphabet a
space and a stop you want to have an
anode for each one of those that shows
what's the probability of that node
being next so we need this dense layer
to force the network to give the number
of outputs that we want for our
particular Y data
and so then lastly once we have that
dense layer we don't need an activation
layer and the activation layer is there
to ensure that these are probabilities
so they need to add up to one and they
all need to be great at least zero and
so the activation layer is just there to
apply that function so let's go to some
code so here this is from the Karis
package so that top row is just
specifying the input and you can see we
specified an input with the shape you
don't have to tell it the number of rows
because it infers that so it's just the
max length of the name and the number of
characters in the dictionary and then we
have the output is all of the layers and
you can see that each one of these
layers of text actually correlates
exactly with one of the layers on the
previous slide we have two ls TMS we
have a dropout to avoid overfitting we
have a dense layer with the number of
characters as the output to get the
number of outputs we want and then the
activation of softmax to ensure
everything is a probability that adds up
to one so that's our network and then we
use the model to put it all together so
that at the bottom says create a model
that has these inputs and outputs and
then compile it and in the compilation
step you just specify okay well what is
the loss we want to use so what can what
do we consider a good prediction and
what if the optimizer we use and the
optimizer is how do we try and optimize
the network but you can always put atom
and not even worry about it and they'll
get you far for many months so so that
just defines the neural network we don't
actually have to Train it and so by that
I mean we actually have to feed it input
data all we've done so far in that last
slide was specify what the structure of
the network looks like and so we have
some choices so this is the code over
here so we say we take the model and
then we fit it with the X&Y data and we
specified the number of epochs and
they're never in the batch size and when
I started doing all that works this this
beguiled me and it turns out that you
really just have two choices one is for
the epochs this means how many times you
want to go through and fit that data if
there are 700,000 rows of pet names how
many times you want to look through all
of those pet names and try and make your
network more and more accurate and the
back sides is just how many rows you
want to fit at once do you want to look
at 64 pet names at a time 128 256
so the answers are the number of epochs
um you basically can watch how the
network converges and so long as you've
given it as long as you watch how much
that converges and you've given it
enough epochs you're probably fine so
just look at the output graphs and then
the batch size for a small and even
medium-sized projects this really
doesn't matter it only matters if you
start doing the complex stuff with GPUs
and all that like you really don't have
to worry about it just set it to 6400
828 and you're probably fine it's and
then you train it and this might take a
while
and so you'll get from our studio a cool
output like this and on the top it's
showing you the accuracy of the model so
it's getting more and more accurate over
time and on the bottom you see the loss
it's it's improving over and over you
have two different cover lines because
you can split between training and test
data but if you're dealing with pet
names it doesn't really matter if you
have test data it's fine whatever you do
is good okay so when you've done that
you're done you save your work and you
can save your model and unfortunately
you can't use like a built in base our
saving thing because it's one of those
weird Python issues you actually have to
use a separate function to save but it's
fine
just save it as a model call it model
dot h5 move on with your life ok so how
do you use it so you load up that model
somewhere else you take it into another
function and then you use predict just
like you would with a linear regression
or some other R code you just use
predict and you say the model and then
here's all the previous letters data and
keep in mind the previous letters data
has to be formatted in zeros and ones
just like the training data was so you
can't do a little bit of work to get
that to work but that's fine and then
for input letters that prediction is
going to return the probability of each
letter being the next one in the name so
what's the probability that a is gonna
be next or F is gonna be next
and so then you define a function that
starts with a blank string predicts the
next letter and then updates like your
current name and then predict a neck
letter after that and after that until
you get to a stop character and then
your name is done you could create one
function to do that once you have a
function to create one name you can
create a function to generate many names
like this one here at the bottom
generate many names where I say here's
the number of names here's the mollow
here's the list of characters to use and
here's the max length of name and then
you get a lot of outputs and so then you
have that one function that you can run
and
all the good stuff and so with that it's
fun time so I'm gonna leave this up for
a second just because it's really fun to
read just like just breathe take a
moment look at some weird pet names
these are all generated from a neural
network
none of these word names I filtered out
any name that actually showed up in the
Seattle names so these are all new fresh
material go name your pets and so this
is really cool because now is a fun side
project you too can have created and a
function that will generate names and
this is really great and you can run it
on your laptop and you feel really good
about yourself of like oh cool
you know you feel really good about
yourself oh cool I can run this and I
can see how these pet names look but you
may want to show your friends you may
want to make a website so that anyone in
this audience can go look at those pet
names I'm not gonna do that I don't
never do that
but what if you could and that's to be
continued um so tomorrow morning at this
very conference um have there no lists
we'll go through the the process of
taking a function like that and actually
putting it into a production state so
that can be used as an API in a really
cool way cool so to wrap it up so neural
networks and are they're really not hard
it seems very they seem very
inaccessible especially given all the
talk of fancy things like GPUs and
things like that but they're not like
you can do it with not that much setup
you can think about them as just like a
super fancy linear regression and like
your reasoning should in general apply
you don't have to like you see those
weird network architecture so you think
how do I come up with what those are and
the answer is you don't you steal other
people's to start and then eventually
after you do it enough times you'll
start to be like wait I'm gonna take
this part from this network and this
from this and start mashing it together
and well it is you know people talk a
lot about the GPU powers and all the
cool stuff you can do with more of the
advanced technology and cloud and stuff
like you don't have to do that you can
run it on your laptop to start it's
totally cool so here are some barks to
action
so that's are you good that's where you
can view the code it's an open source
repository it's great you can follow me
on twitter at sky tetra and i will have
these slides available
at some point in the near future on
Twitter you can also go to newest
llc.com
you may not believe this but I consult
professionally for companies some of
them pay me and if you want to pay me to
or my wife Heather who also co-founded
the company we together provide all
sorts of professional consulting
services so please check our website out
and thanks to t-mobile in our studio for
a lot of the code that this talk was
based on
you